alors ils en pensent quoi votre frère
vaudois dans l'art et aux poses des
questions aux gens pendant qu'ils nous
répondre les occupants plomb ces gens là
caméra marche pas tout ça on a un camion
à côté on part en courant on se déguise
entre guillemets à peu près qu'au veut
c'est vraiment à peu près et on revient
derrière et ont fait leurs frères tout
simplement nouvel épisode c'est parti ce
matin les transports en commun à paris
je suis pas un gros mot nobel sont pas
mal ouais ouais et votre famille dans
pense quoi chose moi c'est mon père qui
fera bientôt des transports en commun
pas rien c'est bien mais bon c'est
souvent bondés c'est souvent lens et
c'est pas très pratique ou via votre
soif en pense quoi
je suis pas du tout d'accord
préparatoire dessus parce que c'est vrai
qu'on en parle forcément le chemin non
plus quoi les dépassements n'ont en
général oui ils sont tous bien sûr
j'adore
ben moi je les utilise beaucoup et puis
temps semblé assez satisfait sexy money
et vos frères qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent
bon à part à paris
difficultés de transport liées au palais
bourbon ce quoi mais c'est un peu pareil
c'est vrai que vanguard est souvent
bloqué ya un petit problème de trajet
tout ça oui mais sincèrement je les
prends souvent c'est vraiment très
pratique mais après il ya toujours de
tension dans les problèmes on va pas les
blâmer parce que avec tout le travail
qu'ils ont à faire c'est quoi une
pratique d'accord et votre frère et
n'importe quoi du coup au monde les
surprend les transfos amour donné je
suis chanteur y sommes
oh